CDC FDIC possible link between Pfizer's
by valence shot and strokes The Agency
said the surveillance signal is very
unlikely to represent a true clinical
risk and said they will continue to
recommend the vaccine so this obviously
has a lot of people worried you knew
what the tell was it was when the number
one thing Republicans were lobbying for
was were immunity protections and
liability protections for the vaccine
manufacturers I mean you knew at the
very beginning this was going to be an
issue because they had to they had to
lay out all of their immunities and
protection and because YouTube was
censoring anybody who brought that up
how are you still on YouTube like you
know my thread I'm telling you we argue
with each other like if I say anything
about covid for the most part Tim will
be like no no no and then we'll let go
at it and we never make definitive
claims very very rarely make definitive
claims about things we don't have proof
it's it's basically just like look we're
reading Politico here you know what I
mean hey man if YouTube's got a problem
with Politico the BBC CNN all reporting
this well then we're all asked well I
mean Marjorie Taylor green got got
zapped off of social media for saying
that if you were are really overweight
that was probably a bad idea vis-a-vis
covid and exercise would be helpful and
then you you know lo and behold you
later see CNN and the CDC accept those
positions Crowder uh Stephen Crowder got
a strike for citing the CDC yeah it's
but but today's pretty big especially
with this FDA CDC news that almost
everyone in the corporate media is
talking about the British Broadcasting
Company even had a cardiologist on that
they're getting criticized for having on
a doctor a Mainline professional that
was talking about the larger concerns
when it came to this of course shot and
larger health effects that are being
correlated here I know Florida is
investigating that right now under Ron
DeSantis but I see this yeah but I see
this being a very key divisive issue
especially when it comes to the
Republican primaries especially when it
comes to the possibility of DeSantis and
Trump kind of heading uh going at each
other how do you see that larger battle
unfolding and do you think there's going
to be any accountability uh against big
Pharma for a lot of their kind of
egregious actions and a lot of their day
data that they're hiding from the
American people no I mean there are
multiple big Pharma lobbyists for every
single member of Congress you want to
talk about a special interest that has a
death grip on the political process it
is Big Pharma and I don't know that the
vax Mandate in the 2024 primaries will
still be like at the top of the issue
Matrix I think this economy is about to
go through a serious contraction I think
that people are going to see their 401ks
experience real problems I think that as
interest rates rise and we that has such
an impact on our nation's debt service
and and how far the dollar can go
purchasing power business confidence
consumer confidence I think like that's
going to be the issue Matrix along with
the Border in 2024 and a lot of places
are getting rid of the vaccinated I mean
I'm grateful that the Department of
Defense is ditching the vax Mandate the
fight's not over we got to reinstate
people who saw their lives ruined but I
don't see it being a big deal you do
need a vaccine to enter the United
States if you're
so tomorrow I'm on CNN I'm on uh
smerconish's show so I was going to come
into the studio do the stick there and
they're like produce your vaccine your
booster where you triple boosted did you
get a booster this morning do you have a
negative test and I'm like I'm not doing
any of that stuff so I've got to shoot
the the segment remote but then every
time I see like my Republican colleagues
now on set in the studio I'm like you
know we we had on the krasensteins the
other day they're Democrats and I asked
them if they thought the economy was
good fairly good bad and they said
somewhere between fairly bad and fairly
good and if you look at the polling the
majority the plurality of people at the
majority think it's fairly bad or Worse
40 say very bad so we got the story
about Joe Biden and the documents in his
garage
meanwhile it's like nine dollars in some
places for a carton of eggs you know
milk is really expensive I think the
average person when it comes to the
issue Matrix like you're mentioning is
just sitting there wondering why cabbage
cost seven dollars yeah I mean I looked
at the little head of cauliflower that
we got at the grocery store like the
shrinkflation is real as well and we
were talking before we went live just
about how silly I think like the
archivist disputes are like I said in
September probably every one of these
presidential vice presidential libraries
and think tanks in America is out of
some sort of technical compliance with
the record to keeping act and for my
constituents who have to drive a long
way to work and are looking at gas
prices who if you want to buy a used car
today I mean good luck I mean it's I
don't know if you want to drive them or
bronze them after you get them based on
how much you have to pay the housing
market rent being up uh so high I mean
already we made it where Millennials can
barely afford to to buy a house so so
many are forced into rental life and now
what's happening with the cost of rent
you know those are things that I think
like people really think about and you
turn on cable news and it's all about
like there's an 11th document that they
have found in Joe Biden's convertibles
glove compartment and we're supposed to
clutch our pearls and act like that's
like the biggest thing on the planet
Earth the 1.7 trillion Omnibus that went
through a cup was about a month ago
three weeks ago that changed the value
of the dollar doing the math 1.7
trillion to our 31 trillion deficit is
uh or debt is uh took the value of the
dollar from one dollar to 95 cents like
every dollar that you have is now worth
95 cents because that bill passed or be
that yes yes that money was printed I
should say yeah and you can go you know
recap the value if you go to the gender
studies courses in Pakistan exactly and
I think the financial problem is going
to be very significant I I think a lot
of people saw it uh during the beginning
of covid uh I personally was calling it
out but but we still haven't seen the
full ramifications of it there's there's
going to be a lot of responsibility when
it comes to printing so much money
spending so much money that we don't
have what are you seeing down the
pipeline how do you think this is going
to unfold some people are saying in the
corporate media that this is going to be
just a little temporary recession I
don't think so myself how do you see it
unfolding yeah it just it it seems as
though we haven't yet paid the full
price in jobs for what we've done to the
dollar and you're starting to see that
with you know all the what I call the
hoodie layoffs right all the tech
companies laying off people by the
thousands but now we're starting to see
it in the productive sectors of the
economy too and Manufacturing in
agriculture stuff's just not creating
the same investment confidence it's not
attracting the same degree of capital
now fortunately a lot of other places in
the world are have it worse than we do
so the dollar you know has not has not
bottomed out but we cannot drive
government spending to this extent and
so then it becomes like okay in this
world of divided government what fight
do you pick to try to resolve that and
we got the debt limit coming up and
Republicans typically lose fights over
the day that limit if you just look
politically historically because you
know we're talking about some sort of
economic algebra problem and the
Democrats are like yeah well your 401k
will get cut in half you know if this
doesn't happen if the Republicans do
brinksmanship so as that comes up like
what is the thing that we demand to
spend less money on and I would
represent that work requirements would
be the right fight like we send a s we
send so much money right now to
able-bodied people who could work but
choose not to and we do it through State
programs that Access Federal drawdowns
we do it through Medicaid expansion we
do it through different features of
Obamacare voluntary Pre-K although all
those different social service programs
and if you had work requirements in
order to access those for able-bodied
people then I think that would be
anti-inflationary that would reduce some
of the mandatory spending and the
entitlement spending and I think people
could get that right as opposed to just
like trying to walk everybody through an
economic pie chart as the Democrats are
accusing us of brinksmanship so with the
economy tanking can you please give us
some Insider Congressional trading tips
please so that's enough by the way
another area where the populist right
and populists left should work together
I do not believe that members of
Congress should trade individual stocks
we have information that other people do
not and we have the ability to impact
how various companies do based on the
types of programs we authorize or uh or
that we pull and so it's just crazy to
me that that was ever allowed and uh
you're talking about you know big Tech
bills and like potentially breaking up
Facebook and just imagine if you're
about to even vote on that and then you
go and you know put option get put
options that's not a hypothetical that
happened I mean we had bills that were
moving through the Judiciary Committee
that passed out of the Judiciary
Committee that broke up big Tech and we
were all getting ready for them to come
to the floor and on the dip Paul Pelosi
bought a bunch of those stocks wow and
then guess what guess what Tim they
never [ __ ] came to the floor wow what
a surprise are these people are evil
what that's like what they did about
Napoleon the British where they said
Napoleon lost the war or won the war
everyone sold their British stock a
bunch of rich British businessmen bought
it up then they're like actually he's
still fighting so you're saying go long
or short on Teslas I'm taking them
someone needs a clip that Paul Pelosi
thing and put it on Twitter have you
guys talked about like defaulting on the
Federal Reserve debt and just telling
this private quasi-private public
company like we're not you're a [ __ ] we
are you work for us we allow you to
exist and we're not we can't pay debt
that we don't have you borrow 10
trillion dollars you can't pay back 15.
you only have 10. we ain't got it we
take a post-dated check yeah like
because we're talking about like where
are we going to get the money if we for
the debt ceiling thing like what about
we just don't ever want to be your
landlord you're like you know what the
answer is I don't have it I'm all about
small business but I do feel like it's
like how do I get this parasite out of
my brain without killing myself the
Federal Reserve like it's it's in our
system right now it has been in control
since 1913 but like what and they had
one job and it was not to let the
economy overheat so that we got to this
level of inflation and they did it in
1928 right it happened in 28 I mean the
Great Depression was a direct result of
these banksters you know deciding when
and how we can run our our lives so does
that ever come up do you guys talk a lot
about the Federal Reserve and and
breaking it up or just take Congress
taking control of the monetary Supply
well in in our life time you've seen
Congress devolve more power than it has
claimed and so in a lot of ways it's a
way for members of Congress to avoid a
great deal of accountability for the
economy to just act as though it's a
bunch of nerds with green eye shades at
the FED that turn dials up or down that
cause the economy to react in various
ways so the answer is no damn and it's
because they don't want to get stuck
with the bag if and when the economy
actually does crash uh well I I mean I
think that's reprehensible because
that's the one of the sole jobs of
Congress is to protect the monetary
Supply
uh well and instead you get the 1.7
trillion dollar Omni which is why this
fight we had this last week matters
because it's only ever going to be the
way it's going to be until you force
change and until you use the leverage
you have thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time